hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
werdet heute möchte ich mal wieder einen
richtig tollen klassiker machen heute
gibt es nämlich eine käse sahne torte
nach salehs als ich hab so ein bisschen
abgewandelt aber ich zeige euch das
einfach später an geeigneter stelle und
ich werde jetzt werden ich werde das
ganze jetzt mit einem biss gezeigt
machen später die käsemasse noch ein
bisschen frucht wird rein geben und die
käse sahne torte gehört auch eigentlich
so zu meinen favoriten weil ich so eine
quark sahne sehr gern mag und weil sie
einfach immer richtig schön luftig
locker und fruchtig schmeckt und ich
zeige euch jetzt mal kurz die zutaten
für den wiener boden
ich habe hier sechs eier die sind
bereits zimmer waren eine prise salz
etwas vanille extrakt darf ich dich nie
fehlen 200 gramm zucker 180 km 60 gramm
speisestärke neben den teelöffel
backpulver und hier 60 gramm zerlassene
butter und zuerst gehe ich jetzt die
eier in die rührschüssel das ganze mache
ich jetzt mit der küchenmaschine ihr
könnt auch einem handrührgerät machen
müsst aber wirklich sehr sehr lange
rühren
weil diese eiweiß masse also er diese
masse und zucker man es jetzt gleich
richtig schaurig gehört wird viel salz
ist jetzt mit dabei dann auch etwas vom
vanille extrakt
und zu kaufen
und jetzt wird es erstmal schaumig
aufgeschlagen und muss dann wirklich
fast 15 minuten lang gerührt werden bis
die einmal richtig dickflüssig ist aber
ich zeige euch dann eben gleich nochmal
wie sie aussehen sollen
so dickflüssig muss jetzt diese
zuckermasse sein dann ist sie genau
richtig
also wenn ihr so den schnee bis buch
haltet darf eigentlich fast nichts
herunter fließen so fast schon jetzt
gehen wir noch die restlichen zutaten
mit rein und zwar nehme ich mit ein hase
und gebt die trockenen zutaten erst mal
rein
die speisestärke und ein teelöffel
backpulver und das mache ich jetzt
einfach damit das ganze gleich keine
klum bekommt und sich das mehl eben auch
schön verteilt
und jetzt wird es untergehoben immer
schön von außen nach innen ganz
vorsichtig
und wenn sich das dann schön verbunden
hat gebe ich noch die flüssige butter
mit rein
die kommt peter wiener maße immer mit
dazu und das wird jetzt auch kurz unter
gerufen
und den teig die sich jetzt in eine
vorbereitete backform und zwar habe ich
hier einen tortenring mit dem
durchmesser von 26 zentimetern also dass
ich mit verstellbaren tortenring und ich
habe ihn halt so eingestellt und habe
ihn vorher natürlich auch mit backpapier
ausgekleidet und den verstreiche ich
jetzt hier drin und dann wird der kuchen
also datei bei 170 grad ober und
unterhitze für ungefähr 40 bis 45
minuten gebacken und danach zeige ich
euch dann gleich das endergebnis
der teig ist jetzt gebacken und jetzt
nehme ich ihnen hier noch heiß vom blech
herunter geht am besten mit seinem
trockenen retter dann löse ich den rand
mit einem tortenring messer
jetzt legt dann boris geschirrtuch
drüber ach so erstmal den trottel lösen
durch ein sauberes geschirr tuch legt
rüber und könnte ich den kuchen einmal
stürzen ist okay gerade wenn ich bei
facebook fragen über den zuschauern
werden
außerdem schreibt monaten das altstadt
gehört alles super so und jetzt denke
ich den kuchen schön ab so kann er
nämlich total abkühlen
und wenn er dann komplett abgekühlt ist
bereiten wir noch die käsemasse so der
tortenboden ist jetzt abgekühlt und
jetzt werde ich ihnen einmal
durchschneiden
sie stützt sich in erstein noch mal um
damit ich das geschirrtuch wegnehmen
kann
jetzt nehme ich mir eine torten säge die
hat zwar hier so 2 drehte aber ich
benutze jetzt nur eine einheit ganz oben
und das schneide ich jetzt einmal mittig
durch
und diese oberseite der torte die nehme
ich jetzt und resi um damit ich sehr
einfach als boten benutzt sondern
nämlich später den deckel und benutzt
als oberseite benutzt den boden als
bäcker damit er einfach schön glatte und
ich setze ist jetzt hier auch direkt auf
meine kuchen platte drauf einfach auf
drauflegen noch mal stürzen
aber jetzt setzt sich da auch direkt von
torten rahmen wieder außen unseren
tortenring und dann steht er jetzt erst
mal auf der seite und diesen deckel
nehme ich jetzt den muss man jetzt auch
noch mal stürzen
ich hab so wurden kuchen und nicht
stirbt dann kann ich aber besser
schneiden und da habe ich jetzt so ne
schnitten teile also ein portionierer
einmal mit 16 und einmal mit zwölf
teilen und ich mache jetzt die 16 teile
weil ich nicht möchte dass später die
kuchenstücke so ewig groß sind
deswegen nehmen wir die 16 damit kann
ich das markieren und muss jetzt auch
schon mal diesen deckel zurechtschneiden
weil ansonsten später beim anschnitt die
käse sahne so akzeptiert wird und es
kann sich einfach mit einem ganz
normalen scharfen messer eben
durchschneiden
und damit mehr details nicht so
austrocknen setze ich jetzt den einfach
da drauf und steckt das kurze aber mit
diesem buch ab und kann jetzt hier die
creme vorbereiten
dann habe ich jetzt hier schon mal die
zutaten für die füllung gerichtet und
zwar nehme ich jetzt hier eine dose bier
sicher da ist es abtropfgewicht 465
gramm eine packung quark also 500 gramm
magerquark 600 gramm schlagsahne 30
gramm puderzucker eine bio zitrone da
brauche ich die schale etwas vanille
extrakt und etwas von apart und ich
nehme ganz gern die versicherer aus der
dose war muss ich doch nicht selber
heute muss und schäden muss und ich
finde die auch immer ganz lecker gebe
ich zuerst die sahne hier in eine
rührschüssel und lass dir jetzt einmal
ganz kurz so etwas anrühren
und dann gebe ich gleich etwa sechs
zähler den salat mit dazu
und jetzt lassen wir so einfach komplett
steif schlagen
dieser habe ich jetzt kurz im
kühlschrank gestellt und nehmen erzählte
pfirsiche und geest sie einmal ab und
den saft fange ich jetzt aber erst mal
aus weil vom saft nämlich nämlich
vielleicht auch ein bisschen was
sie können hier jetzt nebendran
abtropfen und dann bereite ich schon mal
den quark zu dafür gebe ich den quartz
auch in eine große schüssel die soll die
zahl groß genug sein so dass ihr gleich
die samen unter geben können man kommt
da die zitronenschale mit rein von der
zitrone und ich sorgt für das frische
aroma in der käse sahne torte also ich
finde es schade kötter immer mit rein
wobei zitronenschale bei mir fast
überall mit reinkommt
dann auch etwas vanille extrakt ein paar
tropfen
und puderzucker da nehme ich jetzt doch
nicht alles weil ich gebe jetzt noch ein
bisschen was von diesem 40 saft mit dazu
drei vier esslöffel und damit das ganze
eben auch schön standfest bleibt auch
hier etwas sechs teelöffel seiner partei
und seiner tat hilft ja nicht nur dass
die sahne steif wird sondern die hilft
auch dass die torte später eben
schnittfest bleibt also das sehr schön
beim anstatt aussieht und damit die
torte eben schon stabil bleibt
deswegen nehme ich das ganz gerne weil
es halt auch rein pflanzlich ist und das
frühere ich jetzt noch kurz miteinander
und jetzt kann der designer stellen
unterheben und bei mir schütz dass keine
klassische käse sahne torte und zwar bei
der käsesorte in der konditorei ist es
so dass mal eben neben quark und sahne
auch milch und eier benutzt für die
creme und die daneben antiken muss mit
gelatine ich würd's halt mittag athene
machen aber ich möchte jetzt einfach in
der creme komplett auf die eier
verzichten
und deswegen mache ich diese kirche eben
nur aus quark und sahne
ich hatte auch einfacher und ich finde
man hat halt da keine rohen eier mit
drin und muss da jetzt nicht nur mit den
eiern rum machen
deswegen mache ich lieber die variante
jetzt nehme ich als nächstes wieder den
tortenboden und kann die creme bereits
einfüllen und zwar erst mal nur so ein
drittel der creme damit ich unter den
vier sich in jetzt gleich was liegen
habe die schön verstreichen
dann nehmen wir euch die pfirsich helfen
und gebt die mit daraus ganz lecker ist
natürlich auch mit mandarinen zb
und dann kommt da jetzt noch die
restliche creme oben drauf und wird auch
glatt gestrichen
und jetzt gebe ich zum schluss macht die
teigstücke obendrauf
das schiebe ich jetzt immer so ein
bisschen ganz bis zum rand dann haben
wir einfach später am schönen anschnitt
die jetzt etwas gerd drücken
das geht gut mit diesem tag retter mit
dem torten seite und jetzt haben es
eigentlich schon geschafft die torte
muss jetzt nur noch in den kühlschrank
für mindestens drei stunden
die torte ist zwar fest also diese sahne
creme wird zeitgleich fest innerhalb von
einer halben stunde aber ich möchte dass
die torte eben später auch richtig schön
kalt ist deswegen war ich die drei
stunden ab und zeigt euch sind dann
später wie ich sie fertig dekoriere ich
habe jetzt den torten rahmen mit hilfe
des toten mit ausgelöst und jetzt kommt
hier noch etwas puderzucker drauf ich
nehme da immer ganz gern meinen süßen
schnee das ist zwar auch in puderzucker
aber der spielt eben nicht auf der
oberfläche
das ist auch immer der puderzucker denn
die konditoren benutzen
klasse schneiden mit einem sommer der
macher du kannst ruhig auch aber frage
wie schon gesagt nichts blöbaum was ich
denn sagen würde ich sagen sagt da nicht
sagen oder dass man sagt ich weiß dass
auch war das sieht aber klasse aussehen
hast du das wieder nehmen so locken
dennoch sagen also gut schmeckt jetzt
muss man es probieren
so jetzt muss man hat sich die taten
noch durchschneiden denn wir haben nur
die deckel angeschnitten und jetzt
schneide ich dem rat ein kleines stück
raus also ist es will ich habe jetzt
noch mindestens eine minute zeit um die
tonne zu begrünen
ja
moratti ist eine version oder meine
version der käse sahne torte aber ich
muss dir sagen dass es gut schmeckt wie
sudan hat schon mal ehrlich gesagt immer
ehrlich sein natürlich probieren wird
das ist nicht die klassische konditorin
variante das habe ich ja schon erzählt
sondern die ist alle varianten und quark
und sahne über ohne spaß ist okay
schneck mission erfüllt wie susanne
drucken hat das freut mich und ich finde
es so viel aufwand ist es gar nicht nur
so ein bisschen wartezeit mit drin und
im prinzip ist ja auch ziemlich gelingt
sicher wenn ihr alle schritte befolgt
und einfach die tipps und tricks
beachtet und mein rezept dafür benutzt
haben uns ja doch noch
also ich finde ich klasse schritt will
gut buchen könnt ihr noch was der teig
könnte noch ein bisschen fluch wieder
sein woran hätte das los ich finde seine
ähnlichkeit mit mit kinderparadies
das wollten wir auch schon längst schon
nachts gemacht dass ich mal wieder ein
bisschen bisher für fehler während tina
paradiso wir das machen wir beim
paradies auf jeden fall ist das meine
käse sahne torte und wenn ich sie nach
machen wollt könnt ihr gerne auf meinem
blog gehen auf sell list blog.de da gibt
es noch mal die genaue zubereitung und
die ganz genauen schritte und war wieder
aussagen
ja ich will ein bisschen bedrohlich
sieht auch marie lebt für sich aber ich
will noch ein bisschen zeit für sich und
gott dann maximal bis er fertig viel
spaß beim nachmachen
yahoo
man muss ja